[Música]
no se entiende 5 media de hecho una de
las grandes definiciones de la comedia
es tragedia más tiempo otra de las
definiciones clásicas de la comedia es
que la comedia es dolor y verdad
por eso si quieres contar un buen chiste
cuenta que te han violado
este chiste lo conté yo hace 6 años en
septiembre de 2014 tengo que reconocer
que no tuvo no tuvo muchas gracias pero
pero a mí me salvó la vida
en septiembre yo conté por primera vez
rompió un silencio que había mantenido
durante 5 años
del conté mis padres y le conté a la que
eran también mi pareja que durante cinco
años yo había estado siendo víctima de
una relación de maltrato psicoemocional
y también de abusos sexuales
era mi maestro la persona en la que yo
más confiaba la persona que me tenía en
la peor situación de mi vida
y fijaos que me hizo daño mucho daño sin
embargo
y lo que más me dolió es que la persona
en la que más confiaba
resultó ser un fraude
hacer una persona de mil máscaras un ser
falso
de hecho el tío su máquina
está casado y tiene una hija
me pregunto muchas veces me pregunto qué
es cuando estén con ellas que sentirá
que pensará en su foro interno
pero lo peor no es que una persona de
esta calaña sea un mentiroso lo peor es
que en esa relación de maltrato la
persona que se convirtió en un mentiroso
fui yo
me daba tanta vergüenza la situación en
la que estaba que mentía a todo el mundo
incluido a mí mismo hui a de mí por eso
cuando en septiembre yo rompí mi
silencio fue la experiencia más
liberadora que nunca he tenido en ese
momento no sabía que estaba contando un
chiste pero seis meses después que me
hice un curso de monólogos
la experiencia que yo tuve
emocionalmente y psicológicamente en el
escenario fue exactamente la misma que
yo sentí meses atrás cuando yo rompí mi
silencio
eso me dio una pista que es la pista en
la que he estado trabajando durante
todos estos años
sobre la base de una cosa que me di
cuenta durante esos durante esos meses
tenemos más miedo a que nos descubran a
que sepan quiénes somos que a conocernos
a nosotros mismos y fijaos que
conocernos a nosotros mismos es una
tarea difícil dura y también cara
pero nos da mucho más miedo que no se
descubra en nuestras miserias nuestras
vulnerabilidades
y perder ciertas cosas
llevo años trabajando sobre ese momento
cómo propiciar el momento de darnos a
conocer en especial la joya de la joya
de la corona el proyecto que más ilusión
me hace es el proyecto que estoy
llevando a cabo en el centro
penitenciario de álava donde aprendemos
los internos y los internas a escribir
monólogos cómicos y los actúen delante
de los internos de los funcionarios y de
las cámaras de seguridad
normalmente es la experiencia más bonita
que he sentido nunca la más bonita y me
ha dado cuenta también que la sociedad
en la que estamos
y no va bien
porque nos obliga a ser personas que no
queremos ser o por lo menos nos obliga a
disimular aquella naturaleza
que nos caracteriza
yo nos comentaba a los internos y a los
internas de la cárcel en serio queréis
reinsertados
reinsertarse a dónde
una sociedad cuyo sistema económico está
basado en el sometimiento mutuo
un código moral que está basado en el
premio del castigo y una sociedad
que busca el colapso del sistema y del
planeta
de verdad queremos volver ahí
acaso nuestra sociedad
ha sido mejor o está siendo mejor
después de haber estado meses enterrados
creo que deberíamos dar una vuelta
a entender
que una persona que lo pasa mal y que
tiene una responsabilidad con la
sociedad
no tanto tiene que reinsertarse sino que
tiene que liberarse
porque porque me ha resultado tan
importante esta experiencia de la cárcel
y de trabajar con los internos y de la
comedia porque yo mismo durante años me
sentí como un criminal cuando
objetivamente yo era la víctima
yo me sentía culpable me sentía
avergonzado de mí mismo
de verdad las amenazas daban miedo por
supuesto pero lo que perpetuó esa
relación fue la sensación de vergüenza
que yo tenía de mí mismo
por eso cuando yo rompí mi silencio y me
di a conocer
todo cambió
pero sentí que una parte de mí moría
y paradójicamente fue eso fue eso lo que
me liberó
creo que la comedia nos enseña muchas
cosas pero sobre todo nos guía nos
ofrece un camino
para poder quitarnos muchas máscaras
para poder ser sentir obrar y hablar tal
y como somos y creo que es una
oportunidad preciosa
por eso también durante estos últimos
años que se ha hablado mucho sobre los
límites del humor sobre los límites de
la comedia de buena fe pensando que hay
temas que no se pueden nombrar que no se
pueden decir o de los que no se pueden
hacer bromas
pienso que estamos haciendo
paradójicamente un flaco favor a las
personas que están o que han sufrido una
situación de violencia de maltrato o
trágica porque lo que les estamos
trasladando es que no se puede hablar de
lo feo no se puede hablar de lo doloroso
no se puede hablar de aquello que
molesta o aquello que ofenden
porque decir que han sido víctima de
maltrato y de abuso sexual ofende duele
es doloroso decirlo y es doloroso
también para las personas a las que se
lo dices
durante estos seis años he tenido que
lidiar también con el dolor que eso ha
generado en mi entorno
he perdido personas que a los que quería
mucho también es sabido quiénes estaban
ahí mi familia estaba ya a tope y mis
amigos y mis amigas también pero sí que
tengo que compartir también una cosa que
para mí es importante y es un dolor
íntimo que he sentido durante durante
durante estos años y es que
no solo duele ser víctimas pero me he
sentido muy solo
me he sentido solo como hombre
me costó mucho tiempo entender que lo
que yo había sufrido había sido
violencia patriarcal
me costó mucho
y ahora que lo entiendo
es como que he visto matrix verdad veo
todas las dinámicas todos todos los
abusos todos los maltratos y sobre todo
la violencia que los hombres no estamos
acostumbrados a sentir pero sí que es
cierto que durante estos años yo he
tenido un referente en quien apoyarme no
he tenido un hombre hetero blanco
occidental
que me haya ayudado a entender qué es lo
que ha pasado
esta falta de referencias también de
discursos
y la incredulidad de las personas de
tantas personas
que yo he notado cada vez que yo contaba
mi experiencia me ha hecho pensar que es
importante
aunque duela compartir este dolor y esta
pequeña referencia
hay un dolor y una vulnerabilidad
masculinos
que son genuinos y que pienso que no se
tienen en cuenta y que desgraciadamente
son un abono muy fértil para discursos
muy peligrosos como son los de la
extrema derecha
me gustaría hacer
un chiste de esto la verdad
pero no sé
muchas veces he pensado haber sido el
único hombre que ha pasado que ha pasado
por esto porque bueno porque dices bueno
en algo hay que ser pionero
pienso pienso que no soy el único y si
esto puede ayudar a romper un silencio a
qué gente no se sienta tan sola y
desvelar una verdad pienso que merece la
pena
es por eso por lo que lo único que os
puedo compartir es que si bien los
evangelios decían que la verdad os hará
libres
bueno pienso que la comedia te hace
libre pero sobre todo que la libertad te
hace verdadero muchas gracias
[Aplausos]